Okay, now that we have seen how to do registry naming and
how to follow the true dependencies and so on, we are ready to learn what
the instruction level parallelism or ILP is. So, we will now define what it is.
So, the ILP really can be defined as the IPC instructions per cycle when
we have a processor that can do an entire instruction in one cycle.
So it doesn't need a pipeline. It can fetch the decode, execute, write result,
everything, in just a single cycle for one instruction.
Also, the processor can do any number of instructions in the same cycle.
So theoretically, it could just fetch and execute your entire program in the one
cycle. But it still has to obey true dependencies. So if
one instruction depends on another, then they cannot be done in the same cycle.
You have to first do one and then the one that needs its result.
So as you can see, ILP really is kind of what an ideal processor can do.
Subject only to obey true dependencies. How do we compute the IL P for
a program? Well, we first rename all the registers. So we do register renaming
first. And then, we pretend we execute. So what we do is, we say okay,
in the first cycle, these are the instructions that don't depend on anything. So
they can go. In the next cycle, we go through the same thing and so on until we
run out of instructions to do. At which point we know how many cycles it is.
Now the one thing that you should remember about the ILP and that will help you
realize what it is and how to do it is that ILP is a property of
a program not of any particular processor. So basically, we define the ILP to be
what would this program do as far as the IPC is concerned on an ideal processor.
So it has nothing to do with what kind of processor you actually run it on.
It has everything to do with just the dependencies in the program. So
be mindful of that, because for example it doesn't make really sense to say
something like what's the ILP on this program on the I don't know, Intel Core i7
processor. Because the ILP on the Intel Core i7 processor is beside the point.
Because the ILP is really the performance of this program on an ideal processor
that has nothing to do with Intel i7. Okay, so just, just remember that,
when you're asked to produce the ILP, you should just consider the program.
It doesn't matter what the processor looks like, because the ILP is computed for
a perfect processor anyway. In contrast, you could
say that the IPC of this program on a given processor is something else, but
be mindful of this. Basically the LP you only need to see the program,
you don't really need to know what the processor looks like.